it's such a pleasure to talk with you
especially about this show because i
feel like it's the kind of role where it
feels like it could be one thing and
then it ends up becoming a much
richer and deeper experience and so from
your perspective i want to know like how
you know what was your first reaction to
the show to the to
to the show to the flight attendant what
was the growing experience of it like
i happened to be in la which was total
kismet my husband was doing a play there
um and they told me that they wanted me
to come in an audition with kaylee
and i got the pilot and loved it i
hadn't read the book
um and was told not to
um because they the book is amazing
that they've taken a departure from it
and so um
i loved the pilot but it's interesting i
think
our show we all sort of joke that the
word tone has been used
to death about our show but i do think
it really is a very specific tone
um that everybody collectively figured
out how to
strike on like right that perfect
sort of pinhead spot
um but it is a little bit hard to get on
the page
but i think i immediately loved the
character
and i loved the story and i had that
feeling when you
finish a script or you start a book
where you just you just
or like a new television show where you
want more
and i feel like that
is such a magical feeling when you're
hungry to know more of the story
and i was like oh that's that's
something that you always search for
i think in a project um and so that was
sort of like
the chef's kiss for me and i was super
excited to go in
and it was one of my favorite casting
directors i've known forever
who i think has incredible tastes
sketched on pap sadera i went in and
read with kaylee
and it was just like it was like um
almost like when they say you meet the
love of your life it was like when you
know you know like we just had that
organic
spark um and
i and i yeah it was all just uphill
from there the whole team on the show
was
really exceptional um
from steve to susanna who directed our
first couple of episodes and
um yeah the whole
vibe of the experience was really
incredible and i think
we had a very bizarre growing experience
in that we got five episodes deep into
eight and then the pandemic hit
and then we were the first show back up
and running in new york
in the fall of
sweet jesus what is time anymore the
fall
of 2020 yes
you did it yes oh my goodness gracious
my brain is just like
i feel like we all have a lost year um
so that was
a really interesting experience and i
think just bonded us all so much more
because
we had solidified this working
relationship and these wonderful
creative relationships and then we all
came back
under these incredibly like stressed
bizarre circumstances
and everybody was just so game and so
responsible and so excited to be back at
work
making this show and i think that that
kind of added this extra special layer
on top of it
and really just yeah it bonded us all
together in this really amazing way
um but i feel as if i've gotten super
lucky
from girls to this where i've been able
to be on shows where the characters are
a lot the point is to watch them grow
which i think is a really
interesting creative challenge as an
actor and always super fulfilling and i
think
really exciting as a as a viewer i mean
i personally love to watch that
and we were really allowed by
steve and our writers and our directors
and kaylee and the studio
to go sort of you know
to reach really far in that regard um
and so i found the growing process on
the show to be really
scary and exciting and exhilarating and
fulfilling
that's great um i want to go back to the
audition because i feel like chemistry
is more common when it comes to romantic
caring not necessarily friendship
pairing
and i mean first off am i totally off
base about that
and no no you're right totally and
for so in that case then like what about
making sure that you had good chemistry
with kaylee
at the beginning like what what what how
did that impact the experience for you
um i mean it gave me a lot of faith in
the show
and made me feel like i was surrounded
by like-minded people i you know i spent
six i mean seven total years of my
like the beginning of my career
essentially on a show about female
friendship
and i think that it's something that's
super it's a topic that is
incredibly rich and just an iceberg
when it comes to storytelling there's so
much to say about female friendships
especially ones
that are um
long that you've had since you were a
kid i feel like there's this very
specific
brand of friendship with women where
you've been friends since you were quite
young
and you probably would hate each other
if you met today
but because of your history and the time
that you vlogged and the love that's
there it's essentially like a family
member
you're stuck with this person but they
also just push your buttons in the most
insane way
but you love them more than anything
and that's a very specific type of
relationship
and i think especially as we get older
our friendships as women are so
important and they they are
so layered and dynamic particularly if
they are that type of friendship
and so i think making sure that to
people who are
intrinsic characters to the telling of
the story you know of our show that they
have that type of organic chemistry is
so important the relationship between
andy and cassie
is so much about both of those
characters journeys throughout the show
and i feel like tells us so much about
who they are individually
by seeing it through the other one's
eyes and so
i loved that i got to go in and read
with kaylee
and i think so much of our characters
were very much born in that moment at
least
particularly for me because i was like
oh yes
this is how it goes okay great um and
they
it was like the minute that they said
action in that audition room we both
just kind of came alive
with each other um and then you know as
well that that's someone you're gonna
have
so much fun playing with what's
interesting too
is that you know playing that type of
role can often feel like you're in a box
of some sort or you know they're you
know i've seen you we've all seen shows
that
you know kind of don't let that
character really grow outside of their
relationship to the main character
but i mean honestly some of my favorite
sequences in the first season were
uh you know and you know
any in the fbi office like showing them
what's what like you know
and you know at what point did you have
an understanding that your character
would
get to get to have marks like that i
mean pretty much from the beginning
you know i got to read i think initially
the first
five episodes um
and steve yaki was very clear that
annie's
journey really amps up quite a bit in
the second half
you know she's sort of back loaded a bit
in that regard
um but just in the way that they wrote
her from the beginning
i knew that she
was a bit of an onion
and that they wouldn't just let her
sit unpeeled you know that we were gonna
get to see the different layers of annie
and that was something that i was super
excited to get
to play um and i think
you know every character in the first
season of the show
i think has a bit of
it's almost like everyone has a bit of a
coming-of-age story
for lack of a better term you know they
all kind of
not to simplify it but everybody like
learns something about themselves and
kind of
grows and shifts in this interesting way
um
and i think just as much as cassie has
that in like a super
outward way annie also has that and
obviously they're related to
each other and the way they both have it
um
i think the way their relationship
morphs speaks a lot to what they both go
through
and how they kind of settle at the end
of the season
so i always knew
steve was very clear with me from the
beginning he was like she starts quiet
but don't worry
like she's got a lot to do and say and i
was like all right i'm not worried i
trust you
i mean that's a huge thing though like i
feel like you know they're
they're i'm sure plenty of stories about
people who
go into a project like that with that
level of trust and
it ultimately doesn't work out oh a
thousand percent i mean i've had friends
totally be screwed by that you know
they've been told they're gonna have a
ton to do and they end up literally
being like
all of my scenes are on a cell phone
sitting in an office and
i'm born out of my mind you never know
anything in this industry
there are so many people
i can't tell you how many times i've
heard like this is the next big whatever
and then no one sees it and then the
movie that was made for five dollars
that no one thought anyone would see
becomes like the blockbuster of the year
like
it just there's no rhyme or reason to
what we do and
it's what makes it such a hard industry
and also
so exceptionally rewarding when it does
work
and so i think at the end of the day
it's all about trusting your gut
because you know all of the facts and
numbers can point to
x y or z and you really just have to
go with what calls to you and
after doing this for so long a big
factor in my choices
in terms of jobs that i take are the
people involved and if i like
if i like the material obviously that's
tantamount but if i like the people and
the material i'm like
all right let's do this and so
i just i loved kaylee immediately i
loved steve i had known susannah a tiny
bit before i adored her
i loved the material and so
yeah i mean i didn't get to see it on
the page right away but i was like well
all signs point to yes and my gut says
yes so
i just gotta go for it awesome
well i i wanna and i wanna ask you about
the status of season two
but at the same time but first i wanna
know at what point did
the concept of the season 2 feel real
because i mean i i remember
at the initial in the initial stages
there wasn't any firm talk that it was
kind of a we're looking at this is a
limited series
kind of conversation but that of course
has clearly changed
um i mean i'm super jaded because i've
i grew up in this and i've been doing it
for so long kaylee and i always joke
that
neither of us believe that a project is
real until we're on set and the cameras
are rolling
um so i
you know they had started talking i mean
there was always
talk of subsequent seasons at least from
my side of things
um and of course you hope for that but
we also weren't sure
if that were to happen when it would
happen i mean you're never really given
as an actor a firm
timeline on that i remember i feel like
girls would we would always get an
official pick up
like the day before the golden globes or
something like that
you know it was like we would rap and
then we would be waiting
we waiting we'd be like well i think
we're getting another season
and then like right i always remember
we'd be like getting ready and
we'd get the call that we'd gotten
officially picked up and of course you
were like
i think it's gonna happen but like who
knows
um and so obviously
we were all incredibly proud of what
we'd made and we had hoped it was going
to be successful and then people seemed
to like it
um but you just never know and so i
would say
it felt real when they picked us up
of course with that being said like i'm
sure on set there were talks of like oh
in season two we can do
x or y there wasn't a lot of talk about
season two
at least not that i recall i mean i'm
sure people were thinking about it
um but i also think
our show
was a really big swing
you know it's a very hyper stylized show
there's a lot going on there
are a ton of moving pieces our core cast
is quite big
um kaylee who was
slaying it on screen and working her
butt off
and was also like truly executive
producing not
just in title like she was on every call
watching
every audition tape you know there was
everybody was all hands on deck and then
while we were finishing during covid and
trying to get the show out the door
there was so much happening and so i
think everybody was just
super focused on making the best
possible season one
that we could and i'm sure people like
steve
and kaylee and our other eps
were thinking ahead to season two but i
think
um you know in the day-to-day boots on
the ground we were all just like
really honing in on what we had to do in
the moment
where where does seasons two stand right
now in terms of production
they're in the writers room the news
broke that the show's gonna be shooting
in la
so we're moving to los angeles um
and as of now that's pretty much all i
know
um i mean you know i'm just an actor i
go
i go where they tell me when they tell
me to so that's pretty much it
i mean i'm sure it'll happen at some
point this year but i'm not
totally positive on dates but um
but i know i have to go to i have to
move to los angeles for a wee bit
um and uh and that they've been riding
away
i know they're having a great time so i
always am
like if i knew how to hack computers i'd
hack into
steviaki's computer and i'd read the
rough drafts of the scripts but
i don't i'm sadly not carly kloss
so that'll have to happen in another
life you have the showrunner's phone
number do you ever just
text him hey wouldn't it be cool if
annie did blank tv yaki
our showrunner yes um i don't really
text him
i think i joke text him things about
annie
um sometimes also annie never
gets andy didn't get to go on any of the
trips that they went on so i'm often
like so this year when annie goes on all
those trips
i i'm like i oh i did text him that the
other day
i was like okay cool so wherever you
guys decide to go this season
can i like play whatever animal is in
the background
like will you just like write me in an
extra part or as like i'll be like an
umbrella
you know like you don't i don't even
need a credit it's fine you don't have
to
you don't have to pay me for the day um
or like last season before we started up
i texted him
um you know we got the call that we were
uh
coming back to finish our last three
episodes i was like is it cool that i
got a bunch of face tattoos and i cut
off all my hair
you can just write that in right that's
fine he's great i love steve dearly
um we all i think shooting through the
pandemic made us all quite close
so that's been very nice that is nice
uh you know something i really
appreciate about both the flight
attendant and also girls
actually is this idea of
you know having a really close female
friend having really close female
friends
and you know you touched on this a
little bit already but like how those
relationships
be really complicated and sometimes to
the point of toxicity
and you know when i i'm curious like
when people
talk to you about girls in particular
you know how often does the idea does
shoshanna's relationship
to the other girls and especially the
way they kind of
did you know she did end up really
sticking up for herself and moving
forward
without them you know how much of that
how much of that is part of the
conversation
that's sort of tough to answer because i
haven't talked about that
in so long you know no one's asked me
that question and
god when did that show when did we
finish wrapping that show
how many years has it been what is time
it's been a few years so i yeah so i
haven't had that conversation in a while
but
that was definitely a very specific
choice that was made i think
something that we did talk about that is
i remember because it was discussed a
lot
like internally and also um
in press talking about the show is that
shashana was always a bit of like
the sleeper confident one you know i
think she starts out
the show because she's a couple years
younger than these girls
being so incredibly enamored by them
and then as she starts to grow she
starts to realize that they're actually
just total messes
and that they're sort of in this moment
of stasis
whereas she's growing beyond them and i
think that's what we see sort of happen
at the end of
the show where she's like i started out
enamored by you and then i realized
um it's sort of like how they say never
meet your heroes
in general you know especially with it a
couple of years in the rearview mirror
you know what is how do you feel about
girls uh you know
and it's and the legacy it's had the
emotions are endless
um i feel
it's funny it it still almost feels a
little bit
like a fever dream at times it was such
an exceptional thing to happen
to me and us as
humans and actors i think
in a big way because it was so
unexpected and we were all sort of in
the same camp that like
wasn't like one of us was incredibly
famous and then all of us
you know it happened to all of us
collectively at the same time and
um i just felt so insanely lucky to
spend my 20s
on getting to
make such incredible material and having
it have such a positive response
and it really opened the door
for what has become you know my career
thus far
and it really over anything
i think made me truly fall in love with
making a television show there's
something really exceptional
about not that i don't love um
you know making movies but there's
something very special
about getting to play a character over a
long period of time
that's when it when you're on a show
where the character is allowed to
to grow and change and shift it's a
it's a specific type of challenge it's
hard to keep finding them but
finding them as they grow
but i loved it and we
had the incredible luck of getting to
have the same crew pretty much our whole
six seasons
um you know we had a lot of the same
directors we had the same writers
and we just created this family and
that instills this insane
creative shorthand um
and it it's just
i don't know it's like making art on
drugs because you just you
you create this base and then you get to
keep kind of like
extending the lines within that you're
playing within
because you have the safety of this
shorthand and of like this familiarity
um and i started to feel that on flight
attendant i think because
because we were working under such
heightened circumstances of the pandemic
um and because it took us so long to
film our first season
um and it was one of the reasons i was
so excited for this job
you know it's something i've searched
for since girls ended
because i did love so much
spending that prolonged period of time
playing the same character
with you know that same creative family
and so
i've really been on the hunt for another
i've been calling it my search for my
next tv home
and when i read the script i was like oh
i really think this could be it
um and i got insanely lucky and that
i mean we all did it was that magical
thing that happens that happened on
girls where
every person involved creatively just
adored each other and there was this
organic chemistry
with all of us from like production
design to costume design to
all of the actors to our directors it
just we all melded
um and adored each other and that just
doesn't always
happen so i'm i'm really excited that we
get to make more of it
absolutely uh there's something about
girls that
i then talking about it makes me makes
me realize i've never really wondered
about this but
you know you know that when the show
premiered it of course had like this
huge
impact and just culturally people want
you know we're talking about
in a way that we hadn't seen a lot of
shows talk like
they had talked about before uh do you
feel like if
that if girls have premiered like today
it would have had a different reaction
or do you think that that there's no
other time period where girls would have
worked than the time period came out
i don't know i mean that's so hard to
say you know
i think the only way to know that would
be to
to rewrite history and premiere it now
and see what happens
from your experience what what do you
feel like the lasting
legacy of girls want to be probably
still being formed given that like it
hasn't been that long
since it's ended but um
you know i i like to think
and it's one of the things that i loved
so much about
flight attendant and about this specific
role
i feel like when girls came out
it it came it like proceeded and also
sort of came out around the time that a
lot of
tv and film
projects were being made that centered
around
female friendships and i think
you know just like i said before that
that's something
i think it's a topic that's
exceptionally rich and layered
and especially as you get
older those friendships as women become
so important um and
also can become very complicated and i
think a lot of times the friendships
that you have had since you were young
sort of start to crystallize in a way
where
you either are like this is someone
who i hate as much as i love but i will
have in my life for forever
or this is someone whose
relationship no longer serves me even
though we have so much history there
and i think girls really touched a lot
on that topic
and i think that was something that drew
me a lot to this job
just like you were saying about the
chemistry reads you know
i already i knew that they were gonna
tell
this female friendship in such an
accurate and dynamic and rich way
because they were having kaylee and i
chemistry read together
and i just think that it's a really
fascinating topic that we don't talk
about
or show enough um and so anytime i get
to
play in that realm play a character play
like a relationship a dynamic because to
me like
i think one of the great love stories a
flight attendant is actually the one
between annie and cassie
you know i mean she does have this one
with michiel
um and with colin you know she
has those two men in her life but i
think
great female friendships are just as
much love stories
as you know romantic ones
and i think in many ways that's the
legacy that girls left behind
and that's something that i sort of
continue to search out and that i'm
always excited to see
and to be a part of excellent
well i i don't want to take up too much
more of your time it's been such a
lovely conversation
yeah uh i do have a couple i
have a couple of random roles from your
earlier career
or not even just earlier but recent
career as well that i'd love to ask you
about if that's all right
sure and one is uh
i am vaguely obsessed with the movie
spartan and uh
i i know i i i can imagine how you ended
up in the cast for that film
uh but i was wondering what it was like
to play quote unquote better one woman
oh i mean that was like literally it
it wasn't even like anything that was
like a random day that i happened to be
on set
with my dad and they like needed an
extra to hold some goats and so i did it
it wasn't you know and i think it was
like a couple hours of my life
um yeah that was like a last minute
thing where like someone didn't show
like an extra didn't show up
and he was like she can hold some goats
and i was like what
i mean i think i think i was like 11 or
something i don't remember
i was very young and i just stood there
holding goats for a couple hours
you didn't have any prior good holding
experience i had no prior goal holding
experience they didn't seem concerned
with that
but they were like you know but then i
added it to my resume after the fact
go home gold holding yeah good wrinkling
yes
has held goats i was like this might get
me another job one day you never know
you never know
i mean certainly goats show up in things
all the time every
every little bit counts to set you apart
great i also wanted to ask about the
experience of doing uh unbreakable kimmy
schmidt just because i thought that was
a really fun
role you got to do and i was so glad
that your character got to come back for
a second episode
oh yes um that was
very fun my husband that's
my husband if um who plays
my husband on the show and um
his uh his best friend
is uh eric gurion who is tina fey's
producing partner
and i guess they were racking their
brains on like
who could play this hipster couple and
um we got a call
and he was like are you guys free next
week do you want to play a random
hipster couple
on our show we were like yes that sounds
so fun
um so that uh
yeah that was a dream for me
um and for him if we you know we
basically just got to
go and like be super silly
um and then we
were i'm i was i mean i loved the show
i loved everyone on it um but also carol
kane is like
a god in my mind so i was very thrilled
about that
um but we were both supposed to come
back
um eric called him he's like do you guys
you know we've written you back in
and my husband evan happened to be
working out of town and he was like
that's okay we're just going to write
you out and write in that you're now in
a throuple and zach is going to come
back without you
i was like sorry not sorry
so hence the throttle no it was so fun
and
we we loved doing that i think the fake
mentos commercial it was like one of the
highlights of my career
that was that was pretty groovy
there aren't many opportunities where
you get to do something like that no
definitely not i also just adored that
show i mean
ellie is a genie everyone you know tina
robert carla they're all just
that show is forever has a special place
in my heart so i felt very honored to be
a part of it and that we got to do that
together you know that was super fun too
i was going to ask like you know had you
have you gotten to do much acting
in do you want to do more acting with
your husband
we we met doing a play together so
that's how we met
um and then
the opportunities just haven't arisen
that much you know and we really
let them come about organically i think
often
when two actors are together
sometimes the project or the characters
can become
overshadowed by the fact that people
know that you
are a couple in real life and so i think
we're very conscious about that
that like we never want
that to be sort of like the talking
piece of whatever we do together so
something like kimmy which was super
silly and sort of a small thing we were
like oh yeah that's really fun and that
won't matter
um but we love to work together
um we just i think wait for it to come
organically and then even when it does
we're just um yeah we're just specific
about it that makes sense i mean i feel
like
it's always vaguely uncomfortable when
you watch something that's clearly made
by somebody working out their
relationship issues
totally they're yeah and then they're
like their real life partner is
sometimes involved and you're like
i don't need to be watching your
couple's therapy session
totally and uh
i also want to make sure i ask about uh
the from wiener dog just because you got
to have some screen time with some great
great great legends and you know
it i know i know it wasn't like a huge
role necessarily but what was that
experience like
uh it was incredible it was wild
um i was super excited to get
that part um i mean
ellen is a legend indeed
and that was pretty exceptional um
and it was only a couple of days of work
but um
i loved and savored every second of
it um and i really loved that that movie
as well
um and that was the first time i think i
got to go to sundance doing press for
for that film and i got to do press with
her which was
also incredibly special um so
yeah that was that that was a that was a
highlight moment i will say
i had i had a very you know there's like
i feel like you hear these sayings
particularly growing up in the industry
there are those cliche sayings like
never act with a baby or an animal and
you're sort of like yeah okay
um sure i've never had to act with a
baby my husband has and it
nearly killed him um
and there were two wiener dogs
on this shoot and it was so insane
watching a set literally being brought
to its knees by like these
tiny purebred dogs because they just
like there were days where they were
just like
we don't feel like cooperating or like
one day one of them got a stomachache
and was just like
sorry i'm out and we were just like
it was like what are we doing why are we
not i thought we were and they were like
we're holding for the dogs
the whole thing for the dogs you were
like totally never act
with a baby or an animal i was like i
get it now
i get it um
i i i'm very curious is did what did you
learn about doing press
specifically from ellen you know we did
so much press for girls it basically
took up like almost our entire hiatus
often because
we were doing award shows and i mean it
was awesome
but i'd done it so much to that point
that
i feel like i had a i'd had quite a lot
of practice and i'd learned a lot of
lessons the hard way
um i think more than anything it was
just really enjoyable doing it with her
like i often i would just zone out in
interviews and then
they would be like and sorry sasha and i
would be like oh yeah what sorry
like i just felt like i was a fly on i
just wanted to watch her talk about
stuff
i just wanted to watch her talk i was
like i i just want to sit here and watch
you talk
um or like make the press people go away
and just
sit here and talk to you over t um
so yeah but absolutely she's a
pro and was amazing and
um i think the biggest thing that is
still
so hard when doing press is how to not
answer
a question you don't want to answer
gracefully
like without just saying i i to this
point
i just say i don't want to answer that
question
you know i just i'm blatant about it i'm
like sorry i'm not gonna answer that
question
but it's always incredible to watch a
season pro
not answer a question but still answer
it
in a way that the interviewer like
somehow feels like they actually got an
answer to the question they asked when
they totally didn't
and she was a ace at that she could do
that like without skipping a beat i was
like
you just fully answered a different
question
like not even about this movie and the
interview was like yes
totally absolutely uh-huh because i
don't know it's like
not like snake it's like she knew how to
like snake charm them and i think that's
probably just like
years in the saddle of knowing how to
navigate that
um and it was flawless and that was
something that
i didn't learn how to do it from her but
i certainly was impressed
by watching her do it i think i've been
on the other side of that
and yeah it's always like it it's it's
masterful when it's done totally like
and then you probably go through your
notes and you're like wait they didn't
answer
i thought they answered that question
and you're like why do i have a weird
thing about their mom's casserole in
here
like how did that happen
they just like they just wove that tail
they tricked you
it did but often i think i actually on
to be completely honest what often
happens
is the answer you get isn't necessarily
what you're looking for but it's always
usually
a pretty interesting story absolutely i
mean and i think that's how they do it
they still give you interesting
information
it's just they probably didn't want to
give you an answer to the question you
asked
oh yeah but they give you something else
that makes you feel like you've got
something still
and you probably did but it's just it's
yeah it's fascinating when you get to
see that in action you're like
oh well played yes i'm just really glad
in the course of this conversation you
haven't said to me i don't want to
answer that question
no you did you didn't ask any
uncomfortable questions
i find it rare that that happens yeah
most people are pretty flood i think
yeah i think so um
well now that we've established that i
haven't made you feel totally
uncomfortable um
uh i i do want to make uh before we wrap
up i i'm curious uh
you know you've got season two of flight
attendant on the horizon
uh you're doing a little work right now
uh what can you tease about what's
coming up for you
um i i've sort of been
holding a beat to see you know
what interesting things would come up
potentially
in our hiatus before flight attendant
would go back but i haven't been
pressing anything you know i think
if the pandemic taught us anything it's
that like
taking a break isn't necessarily a bad
thing and i've been taking this time
to work on a lot of things that i
wanted to develop i'm working on
it's nothing that's been announced yet
so i'm gonna be very vague about it all
but i'm working on two
writing projects um
not screenwriting um
which are taking up quite a bit of time
and are
super fun and like a really it started
during the pandemic when
work was not available and we didn't
know when it would be
and so there are projects that have been
bouncing around in my brain for quite
some time and i was like you know what
i'm gonna
i'm gonna um get these going so
um i just sold to a publisher which
um who i love and i feel very excited i
adore my editor so i'm working on those
um and then i have a couple other things
like some things i have optioned and
some stuff that i have in development
something
of my own and a few things with friends
and just sort of like
um kind of like planting a little a
little garden
of projects and uh and seeing what grows
first
and then just waiting to go back to my
flight attendant day job
it sounds like uh your interest right
now is in kind of helping
to really craft the stories that you're
going to eat yeah
i mean i obviously like you know i'm
doing these
these things this week that came up and
um you know i've been reading
a lot and i if i've
i'm super open if something were to come
up that were
to really excite me or
um yeah just like sort of
hit that funny bone in the right way um
i love what i do as an actor and i'm
always down
to do it but um i think the sad thing
about what
uh happened with the pandemic is there's
much less being made
it costs so much more to make it with
all the covered protocols
which obviously are so necessary but so
there's just a lot less material out
there and so there aren't
as many opportunities and also there's
less
to choose from in terms of what calls to
you
so i've just been trying to be kind of
like open hand about that
and trust that if the right thing comes
before we go back to flight attendant
that's great
but i love developing stuff
i love seeing things go from a seed into
full bloom
um and i've gotten to really dive in
with
some creative folks that i'm super close
with
so that's also been really fun to create
things with
good friends so yeah i've just been
trying to take advantage of that
well thank you again so much for doing
this today um yeah
and i'm really excited to see what
happens with season two and
beyond thank you it was so nice chatting
with you
nice chatting with you too have a great
rest of your day you too bye